und herzlich willkommen bei kochen
lernen mit Joe Russell hier lernen Sie
alles was sie nicht kennen und dies ist
mehr wie Simone aber keine Angst die
haben schon die aller blödersten zurecht
gebogen
[Musik]
Zuschauer was der Unterschied ist
zwischen einem Kartoffel und einem Ei ja
probieren
in was für einer Hand halte ich das Ei
und in was für einer den Kartoffel
ich weiß der Zuschauer nicht weil der
ist nämlich so blöd wie ein von
Bohnenkraut am
besten ist gut Kartoffel
[Musik]
aber ich glaube zuerst
vor dem Ei ja spinnt jetzt du komplett
[Musik]
eine ernste Angelegenheit nicht leben
verabschieden wir uns und wir sehen uns
beim nächsten Mal wenn es heißt was war
zuerst da der Kartoffel oder der
Landwirtschaft
natürlich war zuerst der Landwirt dabei
der musst du den Kartoffel jetzt
pflanzen
genau und vorm Landwirt der Kartoffel
und der Landwirt aber wann war Tina
genau und dann hat es ei die Henne
[Musik]
[Applaus]